doing the work for somebody without them
involved in it is never the right answer
for example my mother washed all my
clothes and did everything for me my
whole life when I went to college and
then started Living with myself I didn't
even understand what people were talking
about will I pick up my clothes I'm like
I don't know that's a thing I didn't
even know what a hamper was I swear to
God as beautiful as that is of a story
of my mother who worked her face off
with no help no nothing it still wasn't
good for me if she taught me how to put
it in the hand together I know you
haven't been doing it but you're 14 now
you're n now you're seven you're 13
you're 16 you're going to college in a
year if she showed it to me with me than
it would have
been